[Music]
so a a son
carjacked his own mother
isn't that normal she had it coming
though dude wait like she was in the car
and then he [ __ ] put on abandon
and [ __ ] scared this [ __ ] up or stole
her car he was next to her in the car
and he put on a band-aid and he turned
he's like give me the car
she's like oh [ __ ] okay just take it
whoa whoa whoa holy [ __ ] i didn't see
this [ __ ] coming he's like who are you
just don't hurt my son she's like one of
the tables have turned
it's like a little baby doing peek-a-poo
mitch gets scared and [ __ ] she was
focused on driving she shouldn't even
see what happens yeah she's focused on
driving and then he did like a deep
breath before he took his mask out like
okay let's do this or he pulled his seat
all the way back yeah and then came up
with the mask
i was like yo i'll give you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like where the [ __ ] did you come
from who are you and she's like oh [ __ ]
yeah but he goes like this he goes like
this
peekaboo
dude
they rented a hyundai elantra oh good
car they got into an argument over fast
food it usually is yeah it always
mcdonald's
made me
like cert like made me happy in many
ways but also it was a root of a lot of
past relationship fights
really
it is the common denominator because
i think fast food is is not the first
resort for most people it's almost the
last resort right and you're hangry yeah
that's a great one yeah if i could
think of a lot of issues in my
relationships in the past yeah five
girlfriends back to back
mcdonald's drive-through that was one of
the common denominators what would the
issue be that they don't want mcdonald's
no no like you're just fighting you
don't i mean it's one of those things
you fight for no reason it's never about
the thing and then when you get that
[ __ ] hamburger and you eat
you forget yeah and everything's cool so
it saves your relationship
it yeah that's true
just a commercial for mcdonald's i'm
saving it what it feels like an
ultimatum right every time you go
through yeah so just like do or die do
or die and then but at the end though
when you [ __ ] get the fries and
everything it's just like it kind of
just you just feel good about this joe
you're you get your order or no you
don't get all of your order they [ __ ]
up and didn't get you two of your
burgers that you ordered but your chick
got her full order oh and your fries are
hella soggy oh and then she's already
digging in and you and you realize that
it's not what you wanted and you wanted
a coconut gave you diet yeah and no diet
coke
see you dude now i know why people crawl
into the [ __ ] drive-through and beat
the [ __ ] out of the register people
yeah dude the videos of them like
pulling the register people out of the
[ __ ] oh my god dude
so yeah um they rented a hyundai elantra
got into an argument over fast food he
insisted that he'd be allowed to drive
and she said no then
she noticed that he had a pocket knife
and became frightened
and that is when she exited the vehicle
he [ __ ] pulled a knife on his mom it
says that she noticed the [ __ ] knife
so he was like clutching it in his
pocket
i mean for all i know she just looks
down and sees a [ __ ] knife in his
pocket and she goes ah and then she's
like my old son's admirer and then she
left she left got out of the car and he
jumped in he says [ __ ] you crazy yep he
he jumped in he i think he slid in like
grand theft auto style just slid to the
next seat yeah proceeded to drive away
he left his mom there he left his mom
it's like those westerns where they they
like show their revolver yeah oh what
the the
problem that's the best [ __ ] devil
strong armed his mom dude but why
why did you do this it was she must have
been a [ __ ]
it was a hyundai it's a hyundai elantra
when you get in the hyundai you rent
that thing that's the new commercial
wild [ __ ]
you rented a hyundai
[Laughter]
it drives smooth though people don't
give credit for that
like it drives so smooth he won but he
wanted to feel it it is pretty smooth to
be honest yeah it's a good car the boy
was arrested and taken into custody they
recovered the vehicle two hours later it
was covered in urine he had peed in all
over the car just a territorially market
knocking
did they have to do a police lineup
yeah damn that's that [ __ ] which
which pecker was it
the hyundai piss
no they found it two two hours two hours
later they find it they signed a
delinquency complaint charging the boy
with carjacking how old was he
uh that's a good question it doesn't say
oldies like four
that's ridiculous dude yeah so he will
be arraigned and uh yeah she's pressing
charges she's passing charges at one
point
do you have to say you failed as a
parent when you have to [ __ ] call the
law on your parent
i mean on your side
yeah i'd say that's about the point
right now yeah but yeah that's [ __ ] at
what stage you're like it's not my fault
it's his fault well didn't you have
trouble with your mom and then she's
like i'll call the cops oh that was bart
you guys ever pull a weapon on your
parents yeah like what i pulled a knife
on my dad yeah knife guys i was like
you're not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
anymore
he basically kicked it out of my hand
and [ __ ] kicked my stomach
might be really legit wow he's the
secret to [ __ ] what type of knife was
it a kitchen knife
i just [ __ ] swung it like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know you know when
you're a kid you're not like really
prepared to stab anybody but you're
still scared yeah i know that's so when
the [ __ ] fists are flying you're just
like ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not gonna
[ __ ] beat me no more you're just
feather dusting are you kicking on my
head oh [ __ ] and it kicked him in the
stomach that's what happened i went
through the side the shoulder i went ah
like that right oh and then he went boom
ah son of a [ __ ] and i [ __ ] fell on
the ground did your dad do karate
i don't think so i think he was just a
man
i don't think so i'm not fine
i don't know if you need karate
to kick a knife no i think you might
need some karate dude maybe he just
needs a boot
[Laughter]
cat william strongly disagrees
wait what happened to cat williams he
got jumped by like a seventh grader yeah
oh that's right right yeah he's like
choked him out wait cat williams got
jumped to seventh grader oh he got in a
fight with the seventh grader i don't
know why he was like at this park yeah
they were basically the same size and
he's like ow
the kid was talking [ __ ] to cat williams
cat williams got mad they started to
fight and then the kid was like beating
cat williams out they had to let him go
that's
that's something you would hope like you
know what the five people who were there
saw i never have to relive this ever
again did he ever incorporate that into
his comedy i think he did like a small
like snippet oh my god dude you have to
you would have to that seventh grader
was like yo if i ever see cat williams
it's on site and all the kids were like
no [ __ ] way dude
i'm like hey cat williams is here and
he's like god damn i gotta kill you
[ __ ] i always said i would there's a
bike
wait where
it starts so small
they are seventh graders though where is
he yeah where is he i don't even see him
where i don't this is a bad video man
oh it gets up where they're at a wall or
something oh here they see
to be fair though i think there's some
seventh graders out there that kick all
their ass
is it cat williams like five feet yeah
he's pretty think he's about my size
yeah because i mean like if it's a
samoan seventh grader we're done man no
martial art could help you
someone samoa
you can't really see him fighting
do this
is this
so that's cat williams
are you [ __ ] dude he looks like a
seventh grader
why are they both at the same time
greater next to them mm-hmm they're
talking it's like versus the other guy
why why is cat williams hang around a
bunch of seventh graders in the first
place right i think he's maybe with his
kids
oh he just wanted to catch a minor
league ball game
so he's just trying to support his own
kid and then he gets beat up by one of
the other kids
i think i like to go to little league
imagine your kid's bully beats you up
too why's he sitting at the wall now
dude did he already get beat up is that
why or is he about to get beat up why is
he sitting down i'm sure it's about to
happen because i remember that it starts
at this wall yeah ryan did call the wall
no don't sit down he's just going to
kick you in the face dude
you know all the vulnerabilities i know
you look don't make it easy all the
phones in his face all the seventh
graders are surrounding him you know why
does it look like he's a child getting
bullied that guy's taking a [ __ ]
selfie
dang dude
oh oh oh no oh here it goes
watch out dude like how the kids like
the same way if if cat
is taking a selfie if cat williams
defends himself does he go to jail
yeah you can't do [ __ ] for sure right
yeah beating up a seventh grade yeah oh
he's on video who attacked yeah wait cat
willy was the first one to attack yeah
he like slapped him oh no oh no
oh he's getting [ __ ] up dude oh no
this kid could wrestle yo he's getting
[ __ ] oh hey this kid
hey this kid knows something bro yo he's
trying to get him in a new rear naked
bro he took his back so quick dude
that's actually crazy yeah this kid does
jiu jitsu look at it who's the other guy
you gotta hook in come on is that
another adult cat's bodyguard
now he does something huh that one needs
a body guard right where's the bodyguard
dude he's getting a hot dog
he's on the floor still this will look
like he got owned this kid's a black
belt bro
what is that baseball gloves
batting gloves there's a little league
dude yeah i think it's a little league
thing
damn catwoman got [ __ ] up by a seventh
grader the wonder the mom called the
cops you know
why she's like i saw what they did in a
cavalier
she's like that's not gonna be me
i mean if you had beef with cat williams
you're a rapper i mean that's literally
it's over dude
it's over why is that the funniest thing
i've ever seen i've ever seen how come
rappers aren't just [ __ ] drilling
this guy because kat williams fights
with his words yeah so that's fine you
gotta like physically beat him not like
verbal he was a seventh grader
like when you think seventh grader
you're thinking like oh if a seventh
grader beat up a grown man you're like
oh that must have been like lebron james
son you're something like something he's
a normal seventh grader but that looked
like the most seventh grader looking
seventh grader i've ever seen he has a
dance for backpacking down to that
that's not the most
adult looking adult you've ever seen you
know that's very true but at the same
time i feel like he's in a lose-lose
situation anyway yeah yeah but you can't
let a seventh grader beat you up you
cannot you can't let that happen that's
like being on are you smarter than the
fifth grader to lose it
but those questions were hard
it's his presence too because sometimes
you run into some like old 80 year old
little
old grandpas and they're [ __ ] scary
dude yeah but that's different they're
grandpas this is a seventh grader
[Laughter]
during the seventh grade
that great daddy did win a fight in
seventh grade
how old are you in seventh grade you're
13 years old yeah yeah 12 yeah 12 years
old dude catwoman's got his ass with my
12 year old kid
you can't even go see a pg-13 movie by
himself he's gotta bring a parrot to go
see [ __ ] jumanji dude like you can't
even go see cat williams should have to
bring a parent to go see your body bro i
think that's what we learned that's his
punch yeah that's his part kel williams
kid should bring the 12 12 year old to
go watch them cat williams has to get a
permission slip to go do a show now
cat william's gonna get [ __ ] up by
haas bulla dude that's the next fight
that would be a great fight hospital is
my guy dude
has some techniques i like his other the
abdul
the singer guy the other the other kid
abdul is number one
i follow the other guys every time i see
us think of you
we gotta promote the fight how's bula
versus cat williams we gotta get
catwoman's on that show on this show we
have to get him
and we'll ask him how it was to get beat
up what do you think the odds would be
on cal williams and husband oh yeah i
think i think high school is a i think i
think it's even money does minus one fan
can't williams have weapons
we should arm we should let him have at
least a knife
a microphone
a microphone and he has a bomb-ass perm
oh yeah yeah he feels good about himself
yeah and a joint you look good you feel
good it just sucks to be choked out too
i think like if he just like stalked him
that's fine but like the fact you see
his face going like the fact that you
see cat william's face being choked up
by a 12 year old kid i think that's what
makes it so much worse did cat williams
hit him first
yeah
i think he was trying to like suffer
around like uh like the way you would a
kid like back of the head get out of
here with the way you would have kids
yeah you get locked around a little yeah
usually it's the back of your head not
like your face in front of me yeah but
for cat he's already doing it like this
oh yeah it's already an uppercut
technically
alright cat williams
[Music]
you